أجراس البقر مهمة
للثقافة السويسرية ، لقد كان كذلك
مئات السنين ل mehdi bell au
HCD التقليد حتى في فريبورغ نحسب
حوالي أربع ألعاب للفرد
يعني أنه حوالي 250
ألف بقرة وهناك نسمع بالفعل
وقحة وآخرين يؤدون أ
رائع
قصة pascal picq مملوكة لشركة kenzo
[موسيقى]
اسمي ستيفان بروش وأنا
اصنع اجراس الابقار
نضع أجراس أو بقرة ل
يجدون أنفسهم في الضباب عندما
هي في الألبومات التي أصنعها
أجراس لمدة اثنين وثلاثين عاما لدي
بدأ مع والدي ، كان هو من بدأني
كل ما هو مبين منذ البداية حتى في
سويسرا نحن ثمانية أشخاص صنعنا واحدًا
المتشردون
لذلك من الواضح بالنسبة لي أنه أ
الرضا عن كونها في الماضي
صنع جرس لإسقاط أ
أوقات النموذج نقوم بالجزء الأول
خارج الجرس ثم نقوم بذلك
الجزء الداخلي من الجرس
يتم تجميع هذه الأطراف والتعلم
غرقت البرونزية في إنتر بعد أن نستطيع
تخصيصها حسب الرغبة
من الأطفال
[موسيقى]
على أجراس البقر
من حيث المبدأ أضع الصليب دائمًا
سويسرا شاليه بقرة و 2
إديلويس سنويًا أقوم بتصنيعه تقريبًا
2000 2500 يورو شهريا أجراس
أبقار الكوت بسعر 150 فرنك حتى 4000 فرنك
بصراحة لدينا الدولة الأجراس الصغيرة
إنه رائع ليس المراعي و
بعد الجرس الكبير
صنع أفضل الأبقار
شيء من يدي أجد هذا
إنه لأمر رائع أن تصل صباح اليوم
كومة من الرمال مساء لعشرة
بيل من هم هذا رائع
[موسيقى]